c'est l'objet de notre débat ce soir
avec eric berger des mers génération
terrain de la roche molière et yves
pozzo di borgo président de l'institut
lecanu oui bonsoir à vous tous merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france pour
débattre sur ce pas salutaire sur la
validation par le conseil d'état de se
passe à lithaire alors quelle est votre
première réaction vis-à-vis de cet avis
favorable rendu par le conseil d'état
sur le projet de loi visant à étendre le
pasa littéraire est liberticide pour
vous on commence avec vous yves pozzo di
borgo président de l'institut lecanu
oui c'est ce qui se passait quand même
complètement fou c'est à dire que toutes
nos traditions de libertés publiques
enfin de traditions constitutionnelles
de tradition administrative juridique
nos libertés communales sont mises à mal
par une sorte d'excitation que l'on
comprend pas ce que sont et passable
mais c'est quelque chose de complètement
fou
c'est à dire que nous fonctionnons à
tête complètement renversées et la
france oublie complètement tout sa
tradition de liberté toute cette famille
sont deux traditionnels de libertés
publiques et individuelles
deuxième élément quand on analyse cette
logique de pas ceux de presse sanitaires
il faut avoir un peu d'imagination et
constater comment ça va se passer dans
le quotidien
mais c'est complètement fou c'est dur à
dire ce sont des films de science
fiction et le gouvernement je considère
que le gouvernement pour qui ce n'est
pas facile d'avoir à gérer cette crise
et en plus c'est une remontée des
variants part d'un axiome de dire que
les vaccins vont régler le problème et
c'est vrai comme une fois on a des
maladies ont disparu avec des vaccins
sauf que nous avons beaucoup
d'interrogations sur ce vaccin
d'ailleurs la bourse elle même
aujourd'hui qu'à baisser de 4% à cause
de ça qui se rend compte que cette
stratégie vaccinale n'est peut-être pas
la bonne et deuxièmement aussi il ya
quand même beaucoup de problèmes avec
ces vaccins donc l'interrogation qu'on a
derrière tout ça est ce que la stratégie
mais complètement folle fin dans
laquelle s'est embarqué le gouvernement
et que les parlementaires dont suivent
un l'assemblée nationale c'est une
chambre d'enregistrement et le sénat on
sait très bien que comme larcher a déjà
dit oui vous avez les deux groupes
parlementaires de sa majorité vont dire
oui donc la sphère des a fêté le conseil
que ce dette va reprendre qu'il ya déjà
dix en dix ans et sexuelle peut le faire
on est quand même dans une situation de
droit qui est exceptionnel on est
vraiment dans une science fiction et ça
me moi ça ma folle et je comprends même
temps le problème du gouvernement parce
qu'il faut qu'ils règlent ce problème là
ce que je lui reproche c'est d'avoir
foncé comme ça mais comme une comme une
bête en fait comme un
de façon presque y réfléchit à ses
stratégies de vaccination à tous cas
merci va-t-on vers une stratégie et des
réactions c'est la question
éric bérubé votre action vis-à-vis de
cette validation du conseil d'état oui
alors c'est un geste qui est important
de contrôler on a une partie de la
population qui n'a pas cet esprit
solidaire de protéger moi je me suis
fait vacciner pas pour moi je me suis
vacciné pour tous les gens que je
rencontre tous les jours sur le terrain
ce qui est important c'est ce geste de
solidarité pourrait indiquer
complètement cette épidémie on sait très
bien que le vaccin est la seule solution
il faut que la une grande majorité de la
population soit vaccinée pour éradiquer
ces variants et ses évolutions très
rapidement nous n'avons pas d'autre
solution
on sait très bien qu'en france il ya une
partie de la population qui n'a pas cet
esprit de solidarité de vivre ensemble
dans ce cas la personne n'est obligé de
faire un vaccin mais qui restent isolés
pour éviter justement d'être un
transmetteur de virus
c'est ça qui est important en fait dans
ce camp se passe sanitaires ces impasses
solidaire impasse de vivre ensemble
c'est pour montrer qu'on est convie les
uns avec les autres et c'est le seul
outil qu'on a aujourd'hui pour éradiquer
ce problème là c'est pas partout dans le
monde où on a cette fois ci cette
possibilité de pouvoir être vaccinés
gratuitement de pouvoir faire des tests
gratuitement d'avoir un service de santé
gratuitement et d'être accompagné on a
cette possibilité en france de le faire
faisons le et soyons solidaires les uns
des autres on a une partie de la
population qui a négocié ce qui en a
rien à faire est on obligé d'avoir ce
type de démarche qui effectivement fait
réfléchir et là ça à penser mais
aujourd'hui on est dans l'urgence il
faut absolument que ce pass sanitaire
soit efficace pour tout le monde pour
qu'on ait du résultat et pour que dans
les mois prochains on puisse retourner à
une vie normale
c'est la seule solution merci à eric
berlivet pour cette réaction alors on va
mettre en avant un point
oui à l'aise il vous écoute on vous
écoute on vous écoute tu as aimé
je pose je pose la question à monsieur
mc berlivet à qui ânonnent les arguments
du gouvernement
est ce que le fait qu'ils soient
vaccinés est ce qu'il transmet plus du
tout le coc vide
est ce que le fait aussi de diviser la
france comme l'a fait vous avez vu les
lélés les mots de l'agression qu'il aa
contre ceux qui s'interrogent sur le mac
sida seront les traîtres en bâtiment de
mais même en les mettant au ban de la
société
est-ce que je crois que vous êtes maire
monsieur mais ça me choque profondément
vous êtes vous un garant des libertés
communales je vous avais un discours qui
reprend bêtement les uns et les les
arguments du gouvernement c'était dur je
considère que c'est une faute
il faut s'interroger il y en a qui
veulent pas le vaccin il s'interroge moi
même je vais me faire vacciner mais mon
médecin m'a déconseillé bon vaccin parce
qu'il sait très bien que dans les
services de cardiologie
il ya de plus en plus de thrombose de
plus en plus de malades et c'est pour ça
sinon moi je suis rennais vacciner et
deuxièmement même si je suis vacciné je
continue à donner le coup vide alors
arrêtez de dire des bêtises
arrêtez de prendre à partie le fait que
ceux qui s'interrogent la vaccination ne
sont pas solidaires des autres c'est
faux c'est entièrement faux
vous êtes en train de fracturer la
france arrêté je vous en prie je sais
très bien que vous êtes devait être en
marche comme ça et vous avez besoin de
soutenir le gouvernement je vous
comprends on a tous été comme ça mais là
franchement ce n'est plus impossible je
crois qu'il faut qu'on rentre dans une
interrogation où il faut s'interroger
moi je comprends le gouvernement je
comprends ces difficultés je comprends
que c'est pas simple pour lui mais je
veux su placer ce que je conteste c'est
d'avoir ces stratégies vaccinales à tout
crin il ya peut-être s'interroger
il faut peut-être aussi d'autres
discours passionné cours de haine et
d'agressions que vous avez qui relie la
yole discours data loup d'autres et ça
je crois que ce n'est pas possible dans
un pays comme la france
voilà je vous dis ça parce que vous êtes
processus profondément choquant ce que
la façon dont vous donner les arguments
du gouvernement et le gouvernement
d'ailleurs à tort parce qu'on ne sont
tous pour la vaccination si on était sûr
que la vaccination arrêter le virus ont
ce n'est pas le cas les lâchers de la
bourse aujourd'hui le nombre de dés des
pays comme l'angleterre ou comme le ou
comme israël on voit que la langue on
voit que la rétine à sion n'a pas
vraiment ralenti les interrogations de
beaucoup de scientifiques les
interrogations de makhlouf les
interactions de même montagne et les
intronisations de beaucoup de structures
canalise les choses qui se rend compte
que finalement ce
ce virus de conduire le maîtrise pas et
que donc on donne une solution simple
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne maîtrise
pas et je me tâte une solution qui va
croître aussi des choses c'est
l'interrogation laisser les français
or leurs interrogations moi je préférais
qu'ici c'était sûr plus le vaccin arrête
tout pour le fasse mais c'est la vraie
c'est havrais vous raconter des
histoires
ayem picquenot savoir votre réponse et
eric berlivet juste pour préciser que la
plupart des manifestants qu'on a pu voir
partout en france dans la rue était elle
pas forcément contre la vaccination mais
il était avant tout contre l'extension
de ce pass sanitaire veut vous laisse
répondre arrive d'arriver pour cette
nuance
oui juste de préciser effectivement je
suis mère mais je suis pas dans la
politique politicienne je suis un élu de
terrain pragmatique en essayant de
trouver des solutions pour vivre
ensemble le mieux possible dans de
bonnes conditions et je fais ça depuis
2014 sur la commune et ça se passe très
bien mais de façon très générale vivre
ensemble ça veut dire qu'il ya des des
règles des droits et des devoirs et ses
droits à ses devoirs c'est le droit de
respecter l'autre et ça c'est la base on
est là pour vivre ensemble sinon on vit
sur le plateau du larzac tout seul et
isolé et il ya plus de problème mais
voilà moi je vraiment je suis pas dans
une politique politicienne
comme vous en avez l'habitude parce que
cela fait des années que vous êtes élu
où vous avez été élu réélu et moi je
suis vraiment un jeune élu entre
guillemets dans les réalités du
quotidien
mais si ça vous choque j'en suis
vraiment désolé parce que au contraire
je préférais compost entendez qu'on
trouve des solutions ensemble où
justement qu'on veut construire un idéal
qui fonctionne le mieux possible
mais aujourd'hui pour moi l'urgence
c'est ça c'est trouver une solution pour
éradiquer cette maladie qui est parce
que française mais qui est mondial et on
peut se poser la question c'est assez
inédit comme situation
il faut qu'on trouve des solutions
rapides et efficaces parce que
effectivement c'est c'est quelque chose
qui est compliqué à gérer
je suis pas médecin je suis pas
scientifique
j'écoute et je fais confiance aux
professionnels et pas uniquement aux
réseaux sociaux qui racontent beaucoup
de choses avec des théories plus
simpliste moi je suis vraiment très
pratique j'aime le concret et la
réalisation du terrain c'est ce qui
m'importe tu voudrais revenir sur la sur
la décision du conseil d'état parce qu
on se souvient en fait qu il y a
quelques semaines le conseil d'état
avait validé déjà se passe sanitaire
lorsqu'une association des forces de
liberté l'avait contesté
il y à un mois estimant que le
dispositif divulgue de façon injustifiée
des données personnelles
ce recours a été rejeté par le conseil
d'état car elle ne concernait pas les
activités du quotidien ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui a changé leur
jugement selon vous vous laisse répondre
en premier il faut pozzo di borgo
écoutez j'ai pas regardé le conseil
d'état mais en fait cette décision me
surprend bon c'est bien qu'au conseil
d'état y ait de plus en plus de
nominations politiques a de moins en
moins de juristes bon je connaisse agtp
la politique mais je respecte c'est une
structure étatique c'est une structure
je veux dire juridique l'une des plus
hautes autorités administratives je ne
peux que respecter ce qui décide je n'en
pense pas moins
pourquoi il en est fier ça je ne sais
pas je n'ai pas lu les l'arrêté je n'ai
pas lu en fait ce qu'ils ont décidé leur
décision non je peux pas dire autre
chose
la seule chose je vais dire à monsieur
vers l'hiver je comprends très bien ce
qu'il ressent mais je les pose une
question est ce que le fait d'être
vacciné fait en sorte qu'il ne va plus
transmettre le corry devait poser la
question deuxième question je les poser
et je préfère aussi longtemps avec lui
parce que moi aussi j'aimerais bien que
lassé de la vaccination soit une
solution mais est-ce que l'acier d'une
solution à tout va comme lé résout le
problème alors qu'on a un tas d'exemples
qui montrent au contraire la seule chose
que ça apporte c'est que là quand vous
avez le coc vite c'est beaucoup moins
violent mais ça n'arrête pas du tout la
transmission de la transmission le voit
très bien les variants et même certains
comme montanier qui n'est pas n'importe
qui c'est quand même lui qui a découvert
le virus du sida qui vous explique s'il
voulait que les variances on peut venir
son profit son arrive justement parce
qu'on a une multiplication de la de la
vaccination
donc moi je ne sais pas je suis pas je
suis pas du tout comme vous aimez décès
je comprends très bien quand s'interroge
je sais que mes collègues parlementaires
aussi s'interroge parce qu'ils ont
tellement d'avis différents qui savent
pas quoi faire ce que je constate quand
même c'est que conseil scientifique
accompagne le président il n'y a aucun
épi diome légiste ce qui n'est pas
normal il n'y a que des sociologues
chose comme ça c'est pas normal c'est
eux qui prennent décision que le
président donc moi je comprends très
bien que le débat médical est un débat
difficile et qui n'est pas facile à
manger plusieurs collègues que
parlementaire je redis mais comment
qu'est ce que décide et il vaut d'écouté
on est un peu perdu avec le débat et
scientifique
ils sont perdus tout le monde est perdu
et de la part du gouvernement je
regrette que le gouvernement ne fasse
pas l'effort justement de mettre ce
débat scientifique sur la table et de
donner de solution le gouvernement là
avant un star slogan il faut vacciner
très bien fait d'ailleurs je suis encore
hier le film qui fait vous piquez la vie
resplendit enfin c'est j'espère que ça
mais manifestement on sait très bien que
ce n'est pas ça on a des exemples de
pays en est un exemple de beaucoup de
choses on voit très bien que la petit la
situation n'est pas une politique qui
peut résoudre ce problème là voilà si
c'était fait moi je serai le premier vin
watier dès ce soir j'irai dans un
hôpital me faire vacciner et j'ai les
voûtes à cause de ça il ya plus de ça ça
compte et les conséquences l'onu mon
médecin m'a déconseillé de le faire pour
différentes raisons de santé personnels
notamment de thrombose voilà heribert
débattre et pons allez-y pour la
vaccination la vaccination limitent la
transmission du fait de stopper le
premier niveau pour éviter justement
l'addiction des parieurs
alors évidemment il ya plein de de deux
techniciens de spécialistes qui donnent
des informations moi c'est l'information
que j'ai c'est l'information des
professionnels qui explique que
justement en étant paxil et on évite le
développement du virus on stabilise et
on évite les mutations parce que
évidemment c'est c'est ce que certains
vivent deux éclairs mais moi je vous dis
je suis pas épidémiologistes ni
techniciens ni jeu en soit les
informations officielles de la rs qui
est un organe public sérieux
je reçois les informations des services
de santé qui nous donne les informations
très saine et sérieuse et vous regardez
l'ensemble des vrais professionnels qui
connaissent parfaitement ses métiers des
virus évidemment c'est la solution de se
faire vacciner
c'est la solution pour limiter l'autre
solution c'est chacun chez soi pour
éviter justement la transmission mais on
veut le pipe avec les autres en effet
pour vivre les uns avec les autres
donc c'est le seul outil aujourd'hui en
notre possession pour avancer
malheureusement on n'a pas d'autre
solution
et pour continuer dans cette solution là
le pass signer terre évidemment et
complémentaires pour qu'on ait une vie
sociale respectueuse des uns des autres
parce qu'on n'a pas d'autres outils
aujourd'hui on n'a pas d'autres outils
si quelqu'un a des outils pour continuer
à avancer dans cette pandémie
ben il faut le proposez vous
un moment parce que je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui viennent nous les
conseillers pour essayer d'avancer mais
moi aujourd'hui pour moi c'est la seule
solution ce sera le mot de la fin merci
à vous deux eric berlivet et yves pozzo
di borgo d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
pour débattre sur la validation par le
conseil d'état de ce pass sanitaires et
de ce projet de loi qui sera je le
rappelle dès demain à l'assemblée
nationale avant d'être jeudi au sénat
merci encore une fois vous de eric
berlivet vers génération terrain de la
roche molière et yves pozzo di borgo
président de l'institut lecanu